while many of you may say they had a
million's enough trust me if you come up
showing your goals set them higher you
cannot get to where you want operating
and thinking with poverty behavior you
don't need 22 mentors study two people
deep that have gotten it right what a
sore get a mentor
what's up believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today let's learn
from one of the best grant cardone and
how to become a millionaire mentor me
grant also if you want to know what
grant and other successful entrepreneurs
have to say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below
you have to go build self-confidence
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one decide to be a multimillionaire
hey grant cardone here i want to share
with you ten steps that will ensure that
you become a millionaire in your
lifetime number one step decide to
become a multimillionaire
do not shoot for millionaire while many
of you may say may have millions enough
trust me if you come up short on your
goals set them higher most of us fail
when it comes to goal-setting we come up
short of what we wanted fail high rather
than setting too low a target in the
beginning I made this mistake my whole
career my entire career number one
biggest mistake was I went for a target
that was too low so to become a
millionaire set your target at becoming
a multi-millionaire I would say 10 or
even 20 if you can think that big rule
number 2
stop all poverty behavior number 2 stop
all poverty behavior all poverty
behavior by the way I know people that
have money that act like they're still
in poverty you all know somebody like
that people that are rich they still buy
strawberries on sale people that are
rich they grind people in a car deal
people that are rich when the contractor
comes over they're like no as to how I
got to get two more bids and they grind
in and they put in the end then they
still don't do the kitchen they waste
three contractors time they have plenty
of money sitting in to me and it won't
spend any of it because oh my god I got
to think about this this $800 higher
than I thought it was gonna be and
they're sitting on tons of dough that's
poverty behavior and it will hold you
back from getting what you want okay you
cannot get to where you want operating
and thinking with poverty behavior drugs
on the weekend alcohol in the weekend
buying stuff rather than investing
wasting weekends beaches tell the guy
yesterday dude what are you doing the
beach this weekend ain't got any money
my my my uh my barber table the barber
23 they do what are you going to the
beach let's spend time my family you
ain't earned it yet but government
dependence being on programs shortcuts
and I'm not saying some people don't
need to be on the program but here's the
deal once you're in the program people
tend to get stuck on the program can't
ever get off of it
victim mentality somebody did something
to me as poverty behavior nobody did
anything to me I was in the wrong place
at the wrong time and I put my ass there
not reading I don't like to read who
cares man
readers or earners refusing the network
and travel is also poverty behavior rule
number three study two multimillionaires
number three number three study two
multimillionaires do not take heed to
this do not study a millionaire once a
person becomes a millionaire the first
thing they do unfortunately is going to
conservation to protect the million
study multi millionaire study people
that have consistently developed and
proven because the tens or 20s or 30s
are hundreds of millions of dollars that
they've accumulated that they have the
right practice the right discipline and
they're still expanding you don't need
22 Mentors study two people deep that
have gotten it right study two people
are so deeper than 20 people shallow I
promise you it will make a difference if
you get a chance to spend three days
with anybody that's accumulated 30 40 50
a hundred million dollars I'll promise
you it's a game-changer so put that on
your bucket list I'm gonna spend three
days with a multi-millionaire in an
environment where I can learn from them
it will be a game-changer for you and
also limit your study to two people
not twenty two people that will create
you from having conflictive data and
content and information rule number four
work like a multi-millionaire number
four work like a multi-millionaire don't
kid yourself the big hitters work five
to nine in a work nine to five work like
a multi-millionaire you know must says
Elon Musk Elon Musk Elon Musk Elon Musk
Elon says man I work 100 hours a week
and you work 40 I get there two and a
half times faster than you do
rule number five move from spending to
investing
number five move your spending to
investing
you burn money when you spend money when
you use money when you exchange money
make sure that you're investing money
not spending money quit spending money
on stuff
I'd rather invest $1,000 on something
that can make me money then waste 100 on
something that literally gives me
pleasure listen what I'm telling you
invest money don't spend money quit
spending start investing I would rather
spend 4 times the money taking someone
else to dinner they could possibly do
business with me in the future then just
spend money with my wife and I going to
dinner the four of us can go make money
have a great time create great memories
and possibly do some business invest
don't spin rule number six create
multiple flows of income number six
create multiple flows of income it is
said that the average millionaire has
seven flows of income the truth is the
people that I know that have created
deck up millionaire wealth that have
cream multi-million dollar wealth have
hundreds of flows of income create
multiple flows of income for yourself
your family and your company you have to
have multiple flows of income first from
the work that you do then add value at
the position that you're in called the
bonus you're not going to ask for a pay
raise you're gonna ask for a bonus
because you added revenue to the company
the third additional revenue that you're
looking for would be outside first your
work get great at what you're doing
second some symbiotic flow next to what
you're already doing during those 40
hours a week where you're working for
someone else and the third revenue flow
would come from a source outside of what
you do during the day maybe it's through
investing maybe it's through multifamily
maybe it's through some other activity
that you can do at night too many people
look for a pay raise when they should be
looking for a bonus as their second flow
and their third flow would come outside
their normal activities rule number
seven expand your network number seven
expand your network okay Jim Rohn said
you're the equivalent of the five people
you spend most time with five folks if
you don't have your money right the
people you should spend your time with
is customers
your family now your friends unless your
friends are buying from your families
buying from you you should spend your
five the five people you spend your time
with every day should be different
people they should be customers after
that to create a network you need to
expand outside of your zip code you need
new friends you need to collaborate with
people you need new connections new
ideas that's why this mastermind that
we're doing the boot camp I'm doing in
what 10 days there you're gonna meet
you're gonna meet 300 people that it
will be is it valuable to meet the
people in the room how they think how
they operate how they act what they're
doing what's working what's not working
crate expand a network okay you do not
need more time with your family you need
less time with your family and more time
with a bigger family my wife and I
always talk about let's expand our
family beyond the people that we were
born with I need new ideas I need new
think I needed to know about new parts
of the world new expansion rule number
eight never lose money number eight
never lose money okay thirty years I've
been investing money I don't lose money
I never lose money this has to become a
policy warren buffett says number one
rule of money
don't lose it number two rule don't lose
it my third rule don't lose it my fourth
rule don't lose it my fifth rule never
lose money quit putting money into
things that there's a chance even the
slightest chance of losing your money
that's why I invest all my money either
in myself to my business are three in my
real estate that's the only three things
I invest in first myself I can't lose it
you can't take it from me you can't rob
it from me any intelligence or
experiences that I have cannot be taken
from me the second thing I invest in is
my business can I advertise brand more
get people more people to know me
can I go somewhere can I get known I can
never lose money investing in my
business adding employees is an
investment not an expense the third
thing I invest in is real assets that
produce cash flow and over long periods
of time will appreciate with no
likelihood of the money going down the
like
to me losing money on vesting myself is
zero my business very low real estate as
long as it produces income and I have a
long periods of time it is almost
impossible for me to lose my investment
in the real estate that we buy rule
number nine make hard decisions fast
number nine make hard decisions fast
people say man you're a hard man you're
a tough dude okay look you've got to
make hard decisions fast when things get
tough they say the tough get going truth
is when things get tough
the successful make hard decisions
quickly
that's why super successful people are
often misunderstood they're willing to
make hard decisions that often don't
make them look good and for which
they're later judge the truth is for you
to be financially successful you will
have to make very very difficult
decisions when you do make them fast my
mom used to say if you're walking
through hell son pick it up go fast and
rule number ten the last one before a
very special bonus clip is never quit or
settle and number ten never quit never
settle the super financially successful
don't stop once they hit their targets
they simply reset and go again they also
don't quit when they have setbacks they
recalibrate and invest in the direction
they're they're going knowing that their
goals are attainable their goals their
new goals are important and their new
goals are worthy as long as they don't
quit hope you find these 10 steps to get
you super rich so you can become an
example for other people that are in
poverty for other people that are maybe
just settling and for even that
millionaire out there that's already
started just a concern be super
successful you can help a lot of people
by doing so let me know in comments what
you got out of this now I've got a
really special bonus clip from Grant
Cardone on how to be courageous that I
think you're gonna really enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions had to
move from watching another video to
actually taking action in your business
in life here we go number one what
poverty behavior do you need to stop
number two who are two multimillionaires
that you will study this week and number
three what hard decision do you
to make today
how many heard the same a boy takes
money too that's not true it takes
courage to make money takes courage to
make money not money
that's why immigrants come to America
and make money they came with nothing
except what courage you lost your
courage when you got in the middle class
you trade your courage I'm doing good
you think you're doing good to the
bridge Falls raise your standard Apple
at the core its core value is that that
people need passion and not one drop of
my self-worth depends on your it's
suppose to mean
if you want to learn how billionaires
think I highly recommend checking out
the video right there next to me
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
I advise students as much as possible
look for the job that you would take if
you didn't need a job I mean you know
don't sleepwalk through life